Ron DeSantis that opportunistic Rhonda
santis that guy who's defending norms
and standards in schools that guy who's
protecting life on abortion you know
what he's doing according to Anna
Navarro in the view he's attaching
himself like a parasite to those
manufactured culture War issues Rhonda
Santos has a problem Rhonda Santa's
numbers have dropped drastically since
he won re-election in November I think
it's because he's attached himself like
a parasite to every single culture
manufactured cultural War issue he can
and people particularly Floridians see
through it it's really kind of like an
old now drag queens Mickey Mouse AP
black history courses I mean it's just
crazy culture War has been manufactured
she's right about that but the question
you got to ask yourself is manufactured
by whom